From the source, the water flows through channels
into the terraced gardens of Tipon.
Built 600 years ago, it's an idyllic place.
300 people once lived here, explains a hydraulic
engineer who's worked here for decades.
The ruin is situated three and a half thousand
meters above sea level and is considered a
masterpiece of water management.
"Tipon was a huge ecological experiment, where
the pre-Hispanic people made use of nature
and especially water.
It was used for rituals and ceremonies and
also for agriculture.
Specific hydraulic systems were developed
for these purposes - for example the channels,
the subterranean cisterns and the aquaducts."
The Incas succeeded in channelling the water
over a course of several hundred meters down
the hillside, without it gaining pace,
then sending it in various directions to irrigate
their gardens -- and then on down into the
valley.
A few kilometers to the west is Cusco, the capital of the Inca Empire before the Spanish conquest.
Today over 2 million tourists visit each year.
The city is thriving, its population booming.
450,000 people live here.
But it hasn't lost its unique atmosphere.
The legacy of the Incas still survives.
Even the course of the river Sapi, outside
the city limits, is a testament to Inca history.
Like in Tipon, the water is channelled into
man-made basins to slow down the flow.
That also helps remove debris from the water.
But washed-up trash is the least of the problems.
Much worse is the raw sewage from thousands
of toilets.
The stench is overwhelming!
This engineer works for the Sedacusco water utility company, which aims to improve the situation.
"Our goal is to decontaminate Cusco's water.
Including here in the river Sapi.
The water here is filthy and it's our duty
to rid the river of toxins."
The problem is the many new housing developments
on the outskirts of the city.
There are fifty in the northwest alone.
All generate sewage from toilets, sinks, baths,
washing machines and dishwashers.
The river flows in underground channels to the neighbourhood of San Jeronimo
at the other end of the city.
From there it flows into a sewage treatment
plant.
It's the pride of Cusco.
It's been undergoing renovation since 2014.
With the help of German consultants, it's
being made more efficient.
"Working in Peru's most modern sewage treatment
plant is very gratifying.
It's also very challenging.
Every day we investigate new technologies
and learn about how cities in other countries
are implementing them -- things that are new
to us in Peru."
Most of Peru's sewage ends up - unfiltered
- in rivers, lakes and the ocean.
It's dangerously unhygienic and an environmental
nightmare.
"Human waste generate approximately 75 kilos
of carbon dioxide per year per person.
If it isn't treated, it could soon be 400.
This plant allows us to reduce human-generated
emissions to 20 kilos of carbon dioxide per year.
You can smell the improvement.
The fermentation gas that accrues in sewage
treatment plants is now filtered out more
efficiently - so the stench is far less overwhelming.
Much to the relief of the plant's neighbours.....
On Avenida Collana, for example.
This shop owner has been living here for seven
years.
The street used to be notorious.
"When you came here by bus, the stop would
be announced as 'Buenos Aires' - 'good air'.
That's what the neighbourhood was called.
Noone would visit.
Even the buses didn't want to come here."
It was especially bad at midday.
"In the past, when I would eat over there
with my mother-in-law, we thought at first
that the stench came from the bathroom.
And anyone who visited us would notice the
smell!
We'd always tell them that it came from the
plant.
It's much better now.
It smells a bit.
But it's nowhere near as bad."
Delegations come from across the country to
visit the sewage treatment plant -- on average
two a month.
The stench has largely disappeared thanks
to the optimized biogas facility --
it prevents thousands of tonnes of greenhouse
gases from being released into the atmosphere.
"We're in the process of deciding a framework
for the biogas team.
The plan is for Cusco to convert 2000 cubic
meters of gas into electricity by the end of the year."
The plant will soon be completely self-sufficient.
The water company will save over 20,000 euros
in electricity costs per month.
The only question that remains is - how did
the Incas deal with sewage?
"This is the bedroom.
The toilet, the bathroom, was probably adjacent."
"The bathroom?"
"We assume it was the bathroom on the basis
of the floor plan and the ceramics we found.
Researchers have identified layers of organic
material on pots, with layers of sand between them.
The Incas probably used them as chamber pots."
The cat litter principle.
Perhaps the Incas valued their water supply
too highly to befoul it.